[Music]
we really want to take the time today to
honor one of the brightest stars right
here at CBS News we lost this week to
leukemia Honoria was most recently our
foreign editor for primetime but she
delivered every day for every single
broadcast in our news division in this
building including CBS this morning 60
minutes correspondent Bill Whitaker knew
her very well and joins us at the table
to remember good to have you here sorry
two circumstances morning morning honor
was my friend we went on many stories
and adventures together and Nana was the
type of producer who worked tirelessly
behind the scenes to bring viewers some
of our very best reporting she often
made it look easy and it rarely was and
losing honor has been difficult for all
of us
Donna Rio is near the scene in the field
and I could flatter cajole charm or
intimidate her way into places we
weren't supposed to go and obtain
interviews no one else could get a
tenacious journalist she negotiated an
interview with El Chapo's attorney and
with the Mexican Marines who captured
the notorious drug trafficker the tub
taking us inside the kingpins escape
houses and the tunnels that connected
them in her journeys she translated for
presidents and citizens and sometimes
spoke straight to our hearts I think
that the real language that that spoke
at that moment was the language of love
very happy to see you she exposed the
trafficking of children in the
international adoption market I am part
of a 48-hours team who traveled to
Guatemala to investigate the adoption of
maria fernanda she won two Emmys for her
work I would remember these moments for
the rest of my life and all of us are
better for having Anna rial in our lives
Anna is survived by her husband Miguel
and two children Karolina and Miguel she
was 60 years old it was such a shock and
I mean she'd been battling leukemia but
it came as a surprise she's such an
incredible spirit in this place and
they've been an incredible mentor to so
many kids coming up and people I mean as
you point out in that piece people
sometimes don't know how much work goes
into getting an interview you know
months you know of being persistent and
tenacious and fierce which you she was
all of those things that was that's a
good word she was fierce and fearless
with Anna everything was possible
nothing was impossible when we went on
those El Chapo stories she was able to
pull together things that just couldn't
happen
another example of people that work
behind the scenes to make people on
camera look really good yeah that does
it for us thanks so much we'll see you
tomorrow